you
[Music]
welcome my name is Jessica Talbert and
I'm a second year MBA at Stanford
Graduate School of Business and I'm here
today with Kirsten Moss assistant dean
and director of admissions and financial
aid hi Jessica thanks for the
introduction is admissions officers we
spend a much of our time traveling
around the world and meeting with
candidates to share information about
Stanford and whether or not it could be
a good fit for what they're looking for
in their graduate education experience
but today we want to do something
different instead of talking about
Stanford we want to talk about you and
how you if you're interested in applying
can put your best foot forward in the
process what are some of the most common
myths about the Stanford application
process you know I think the myth that I
hear most frequently is that members of
the admissions committee at Stanford
have some magic checklist that each
applicant must fulfill in order to be
admitted to our program I've heard
things like I have to have a GMAT score
over 700 or I need to work in a
particular industry to be admitted or
even come from a particular type of
educational institution and really
nothing could be farther from the truth
if you think about the last few classes
that we've admitted we have students
from over 60 different countries we have
students from 160 different educational
institutions and we have students coming
in from I think on average over 300
different work environments before they
come different companies and there's
only 400 students in a class so you can
see in reality we're not we're admitting
humans for what they've done and who
they are were not admitting people just
because they went to a certain
institution or worked in a certain
industry in fact I was just I think it
was a few weekends ago we're at admitted
students weekend which I know you've
been to admit weekend and there were two
students I was talking to and one of
them said that both of them said they
almost didn't apply to Stanford I came
this close to not apply and I'm like why
one said he was in a chat room and
somebody told him that Oh Stanford will
never admit you because of the
institution because the university that
you went to and he was he went to a
state school and in the Midwest and then
another student said the same thing that
happened to her and one of her peers
from work had told her they were talking
about where they wanted to apply that
with her GPA and test scores should
never get into State
so luckily for us both of these students
decided that for themselves whether or
not they should apply and are now going
to be entering this fall so we're really
excited about that how do you decide
then whether or not you have a shot at
getting into Stanford
that's a great question that's probably
the million-dollar question and I'm
hoping on all of what we discussed today
will give applicants insight into
whether or not they have a shot but I
think if I had to go to the essence like
what is absolutely most important most
important and making that decision we're
trying to answer two questions on the
admissions committee the first is is
this particular applicant going to be
engaged academically when they come to
our program and the second is what kind
of impact will they have after they
graduate and if you think we care about
their educational engagement because
we're a higher education institution we
want our classroom to be vibrant you
probably know as a student the more
interested folks are when they're in
their learning and curious the better
and richer that experience will be and
then on the flip side we do care and
believe in our tagline we want to know
when we're selecting these students that
they have the potential to change lives
change organizations and change the
world Jessica I'm curious about how you
decided whether to apply to Stanford for
me was about thinking am I ready to take
a next leap in my career not just next
step I had spent about five years in
retail and tech and kind of formulated
an idea of the kind of impact I wanted
to have on those industries but it
wasn't exactly sure what the best step
forward was in order to be successful
and I think knowing that I was ready to
make that impact is what helped me
decide to apply that's great how did you
approach the application process or the
application process I think I thought
about it in two ways mainly the first
one wasn't really about introspection
really understanding who I was what I
wanted to get out of the world and what
kind of impact I wanted and it's easier
said than done for me it took the form
of journaling every morning and then
kind of looking back after a couple of
months and seeing what common themes
there were what was important to me on a
day to day basis and I think once I
crystalized around that I had a really
good idea of like what I really wanted
to get out of it
who I was the second part was about
information Gavin gathering making sure
that what I wanted to get out of it was
actually what Business School was gonna
be like and not just what I thought it
was gonna be like and that was combing
through Stanford's resources going to
town halls that your office would go to
around the u.s. and really talking to
alumni and current students can we talk
about how you evaluate whether someone
will engage academically at Stanford you
know we're looking for students who are
curious who are willing to share their
perspectives both inside and outside of
the classroom and perhaps most
importantly we're looking for students
who want to seek new ideas new
perspectives almost insights or truth
and to do that in a collaborative way
when you leave GSB as a leader you're
gonna go out and have some tough
problems to solve but you're not going
to do it by yourself you're not gonna do
in your own head somewhere so really
having someone who's going to be
leveraging the thoughts of others to
come up with the best possible solution
is important to assess these behaviors
we look at multiple places in the
application the most obvious would be
the transcript and for me I usually read
I'll I'll take a day Tuesdays and
Thursdays during application season I
get to read from home it's my favorite
thing to do and every time I get along
with the applicants and your stories but
when I open a file when the first things
I do is I go to the transcript because I
tell so much about someone what are the
kind of courses you took what what were
you most interested in studying are you
someone who went broad and like to see
how different disciplines connect with
each other or maybe someone who went
very deep so that's step one and I do
get information about how curious
someone is and how it you know the rigor
and course choices impacted them but
perhaps more importantly than the
transcript is looking for evidence of
this curiosity and other things that
people have done so perhaps you were at
work and there's a tough problems to
solve and you worked with others to
figure it out or perhaps you did
research at your university beyond your
classes one of my most recent favorite
stories was from someone we admit in
this class and it wasn't like no was
your sergeants my coven it could have
been
and it was an individual I think he was
in business development in a tech
company it was a growing tech company
and he joined when the company was only
about 50 people and he said one of the
things he loved best when he joined was
that wherever he was there was laughter
in the hallways and he thought that was
a sign of people being optimistic
innovative and then as time went on and
they were doubling and tripling in size
the laughter went away
yeah and he remembered going to an
all-hands meeting and asked the senior
management you know this is a concern
what can I do and came up with the idea
to do a pulse survey the only problem to
check in with the culture the only
problem was he said he had no idea how
to do it an HR survey what cultural
engagement was how to build it you know
how to write questions all of that but
you watched him go through a path of
just curiosity of meeting with experts
both in the company and outside of the
company researching material to figure
out yeah what are some good benchmark
surveys how do we develop questions
that'll work
luckily they had some PhD students in
this company who were doing business
analytics that I could get help from but
the point is that's a great story about
using your curiosity and you're trying
to find truth about this company to come
up with they essentially came up with a
great answer about what they could be
doing differently as they move forward
so hopefully that helps give you a sense
of what I'm looking for and how I'm
looking for it
many students myself included are
worried about their test scores what
advice to have there this is probably
the most frequently asked question that
I get is what about my GMAT score what
about my GRE and the reality is we look
for a wide range or we accept students
with a wide range of test scores and it
is just one data point and I truly mean
that so my best advice is well we look
at the tests and they are important to
ensure that you're gonna be able to
thrive quantitatively and verbally in
the program so my best advice is we look
at it you should take spend some time
preparing what I hope for every
applicant is when they submit that score
and I know it's stressful that you feel
it's at least a decent reflection of
what your capabilities are so that's
where the preparation comes in that
being said though I know for many
students test taking is not their Forte
so again if there's a score honestly in
an application where it's far from maybe
what our median might be and we we do
admit people in the 500 to 600 in the
700s but if I see this may not be the
strongest point of their application
that's when I'm diving into the
transcript and seeing again how do they
learn maybe tests just aren't their
thing so I'd like to ask you about GPA
Stanford says that there's no minimum
GPA but can you get in without low GPA
I'd also like to know how you evaluate
GPAs and outside of the US both of those
questions come up from applicants often
as well again the GPA is just one
indicator but this one is about a four
year period of time often a three or
four period of time so we we do look at
that for us if you think about the GPA
we know that it's going to vary by
institution you know the level of a GPA
also even by major sometimes I find that
highly rigorous quantitative majors or
sometimes more science oriented on
average students GPAs will be lower
there so that's something we're taking
into consideration in addition if you
think about international schools we
don't convert their their GPAs into u.s.
conversions we actually look at the
country and try to be familiar with
what's their educational system and
recognize that oftentimes international
GPAs are less inflated than US GPAs
maybe so if all of that is for you to
realize that we're trying to do our best
to understand what it looks like in your
particular context that being said if
there's if you look at your transcript
and take it and look at it with fresh
eyes on an applicant and you see a point
in time a semester court or whatever it
was where you don't think it reflects
your true capabilities tell us about
that we have an additional information
section could have been health it could
have been a personal situation but we
want that we're looking for reasons to
admit you not four reasons to deny so
any context that you can give us to help
understand you know what your ejector
has been will be really helpful that's
great I like the affirming of that too
we're looking for reasons to admit is
not to deny us exactly and no applicant
is going to be upstanding in every
dimension so you put your best foot
forward and know that those strengths
are the important things let's discuss
letters of reference what advice do you
have for choosing recommenders
this isn't I don't know if applicants
really appreciate how important the
letters of reference are it's really the
one opportunity that we get to see you
through someone else's eyes objectively
what did you do and how did you do it so
for me put a lot of emphasis on making
the selection I can give you some tips
and how to think about it at Stanford we
request two and one we asked for a
current direct supervisor or an
alternative you know the best
alternative if that is impossible or
inappropriate and then for the second
recommendation we also ask for someone
who supervised your work but it could be
from a non-profit it could be
extracurricular or from the same
organization now when you think about
selecting them we really just as I've
asked applicants and their essays to
tell us about the impact that they've
had because this past behavior will
predict future behavior that's the echo
that we want to see in the reference so
find someone who knows what you've done
you know really been in the trenches and
can see your work and describe not just
what happened but how you did it and how
the way you did it might have been
different from others so that means
don't worry about the title of a person
don't try to get the highest title also
I hear a lot of students asking or
applicants asking should I try to find
someone who went to Stanford because
that's important no it's not it's
actually what what the what the
recommender can tell us about you that
is most important the second thing is
after them understanding what you've
done is enthusiasm this is hard you know
for someone who reads lots of thousands
of recommendations this one's a hard one
to wrap your hands around but I know the
best recommendations that I read are
written from both a head space and a
heart space right so try to think about
who you've established a relationship
with someone who really Lucy Azam's a
great word but has a connection with you
and will be able to speak to that and
that's how recommendations become most
memorable and then lastly I think
applicants should think about the
process don't ask for recommendation in
an email you know it's a big it's gonna
take this person a significant amount of
time on average our references are about
two pages I'm guessing people have to
spend at least an hour to to do a good
job on them what's what is most
disappointing to me when I'm really
looking to find reasons to admit is I'll
get to the end of an application I'll be
on the second recommend
and I'll see someone everything's been
so positive and they'll write a positive
recommendation but maybe only two
paragraphs and just say they're
phenomenal they're the best ever they've
done a great job but I won't have any of
that data to help me make a decision and
it just means that this particular
applicant doesn't have as much data I
guess is the best word but landscape for
me to really understand what they've
done and how they've done it so take it
seriously
make an appointment even if it's a 15
minute chat but ask the question
courageously and say will you write it
it's important why where you're going
what schools didn't say do you have time
to invest to do a good job on this and
if someone says they're really busy
that's a good indication that maybe you
should go to your second choice because
it can make a difference in the end of
how much they're willing to spend time
to help you in this process and then for
the recommenders are there any resources
for them or how do they know how to
write them ok the best question we try
to give and many recommenders have
written more than one before but we try
to give them clear advice and tips
Wynnum they're invited onto our portal
on the website the questions will ask
how has this person differentiated
themselves from others that they've seen
I'm doing similar roles and what have
they done and accomplished so they'll
get that and I think it's a it comes
down to that they're willing to take the
time to really support you you know
there's no magic there but they do have
to make that investment and be close
enough to you to be able to write
thoughtfully about what you've done
many reapplications worry that they are
at a disadvantage to first-time
applicants is that true and do you have
any advice for people are trying to
replay we really read them fresh so my
best advice is the person who is
evaluating your application likely has
never seen it before so there's no
reason to explain what's different or
what changed or maybe why you think you
didn't get in some people try to tell us
that just start fresh and look at we've
already submitted you don't have to
change everything but think is there
something at this moment in time that
could be more compelling perhaps in the
last or some way I want to change it to
be more representative of where I am at
this moment but please do if you're
committed to Stanford reapply there's um
a lot of students that we admit from
that category some of my favorite
classmates are doing really good
but they're here that's awesome if an
applicant does get an interview how
would you recommend they prepare for
that interview well first of all if an
applicant gets an interview
congratulations that's it
we usually interview about two
candidates for every spot that we have
so number one the word prepare is a
really good one if you've made it this
far and work this hard you know treat
this as it's an important part of the
process we do our unlike some other
schools we use our alumni for
interviewers and they are all around the
globe we try to match you with people
from your you know your country maybe
perhaps an industry that you're in if
possible currently in so they really
understand you and it's in two parts the
first half an hour is primarily
evaluative and then the last 15 minutes
it's a chance for you to meet someone
from the community so come prepared with
the mindset to do to do both in the
first part we're going to be it's a
behavioral based interview so the
stories that we were talking about
before come ready to tell them we're
going to want to know about what you're
most proud of what was the context what
was the challenge what did you do how
did you do it and then what was the
impact so expect some probing around
those those stories and then on the
second part it's fun our community is so
tight don't Droid my interview a lot I
would actually had a great time yeah and
did you enjoy the interviewer I did it's
pretty expert actually it was really
good at really drawing stories out of me
rather kind of in like intense questions
and by the end of it I felt that there
was somebody that I'd really gotten to
know and somebody who was a part of a
community I was excited to be a part of
so the interview was actually really
great for me and getting excited for
school and that that's a wonderful way
to to help with the second tip that last
part of the interview is it's a gift
it's a chance to develop a relationship
come prepared with some questions that
you want to know about Stanford
obviously but see it it's just one one
entry step to being a part of a bigger
community so there is a lot of
information out there for people
applying to business school I know I
went through a lot of it some of it
helpful some of it not yeah one of the
best resources for applying to Stanford
and I think you make a good point
there's a lot of misinformation out
there as well we really believe the best
information start with start with what
we put out there on the website what's
nice about it now is there's lots of
conversations with students out there so
you can learn about what it's actually
like from the students much more I think
that's more interesting than hearing it
from admissions as well as there's you
know profile information tips about the
applications start there but one of the
most important things you can do is also
go to an information session and we do
about a hundred of them around the globe
and the reason for that is you'll get a
panel of four usually three to five
recent graduates and they can tell you
we believe that Stanford can be
transformational for you both and what
you learn but also how you develop so
you can actually listen to how this
experience has impacted people and their
own lives both from how they went
through as well as what they're doing
now when they graduate so I think that's
one of the best ways you can truly be
inspired but also get your questions
answered and if we're not coming to your
hometown then go to the web we have a
virtual one to where you can hear
students talking and recent alumni about
their experiences any other advice
before I give you my last words of
wisdom or my last piece of advice we've
been spending the last half an hour
talking about how the initials Committee
evaluates candidates but I would really
like to put you on the spot and say
you've you started two years ago you're
about to graduate yes it's just a few
weeks right and I am curious what
surprised you most about joining this
community of students at the GSB oh this
has just been such an amazing two years
difficult but amazing um and I think a
couple things surprised me the first one
is that I knew that I was going to come
here and find really intelligent
classmates really accomplished
classmates people who were gonna make me
feel like I didn't do a lot but I don't
think I could have fathom just the
breadth of experience and passions that
these people would have and how
important that was gonna be to me and my
experience here I could have a good idea
of like what the academics were gonna
look like but not really the people I
was gonna meet and I've met some of the
most amazing people in the world
yeah and for that I'll be really
grateful the second thing that I think
was really surprising to me is that I
expected to become
a better business person here but I
didn't expect to become a better person
um and I really do think that I have and
I think a lot of that I owe it to like
the breadth of experience from my
classmates and the time I've spent with
them what do you mean a better person a
better person
that's welfare yeah I think it's about
having the tools to be a little bit more
introspective to examine the way that I
go through the world my own biases and
challenge them and then really having
the tool kit to do that consistently and
throughout my life so that I know when I
leave this place I'll be able to look
back on this experience and draw on them
and maybe do a better job than I would
have before business school well that's
great thank you yeah I appreciate that
so for my here's my closing advice I
guess this is for all you applicants out
there I think what's most important to
me is to tell you do not underestimate
your own potential there's no perfect
applicant
there's no checklist that we're looking
at of attributes that we require decide
for yourself whether you're worth the
investment to go through the application
process and what I know from talking to
many many applicants in the past that
you spending the time to know what's
most important to you what you value
what your aspirations are and then what
you've really done in the
accomplishments you've had there's going
to be critical to you at this point in
time and no matter what you do
so we're genuinely excited to learn
about you to learn about how you how
you've actually had impact on your
team's your organization's and your
communities and what you care about
so if you have a story to tell us you
know that we're here and genuinely ready
to and excited to read it so thanks so
much Jessica for taking the time and
thank you so much for this Kirstin
really
[Music]